non sono accorto di niente ho detto o
fatto
che a mio avviso la persona più
sopravvalutato del mondo dello
spettacolo è un errore farlo a questo
punto
merda vestita è
intonata il caldo ma la passaggi proprio
ciao sono claudio a che età è stata la
mia prima volta mamma se stai guardando
questo momento vai avanti di un minuto
ciao ragazzi benvenuti in una puntata di
vita buttata là c'è niente di più bello
che fatturare sulle proprie amicizie
ecco perché quando michele è venuto a
trovarci avremmo potuto prenderci una
pizza insieme avremmo potuto non lo so
conoscerci ancora di più no del resto tu
in questo periodo non stai facendo un
cazzo libero c'è una giornata libera che
facciamo vita buttata
[Musica]
iniziamo a svoltare dei messaggi che ci
arriveranno totalmente random e
commentiamo la bene sembra una una
poltrona con la testa scusa sono stato
un cafone non ti ho chiesto qual è un
cocktail che ti piace particolarmente
cosa mi rappresenta un qualcosa che ti
rappresenti va bene allora mi mandi
proprio a nozze gazzosa che rappresenta
secondo me la musica perché non c'è
nulla di più frizzante
[Musica]
non me la sento di darti il cognac
bobcat otc ha aggiunto anche un po di
martini con la vodka babbo ti faccio un
vodka martini lehman che da domani sarà
un bravi ma naturalmente ragazzi che si
è chiaro è tutto analcolico acqua e
solo al col boca e martini pure su da
primato quello
ci si batte prima posso usare questo
spazio per raccontare questa cosa di un
altro giorno sono andato a domenica in
ha dormito due ore siete che nella
stanchezza mi sono impappinato un certo
punto sono entrato marassi si stava
cambiando maglietta se tu vai a
recuperare l'intervista invece di dire
ho fatto spogliare mara venier mi sono
sbagliato non mi sono accorto di niente
ho detto o fatto schifo
non ce n'era
mai in diretta diretta sia accorta
nemmeno le e tutte visione sul punto 11
00 tutto contento l'intervista super
liceo esco dallo studio formica era ma
ti sei reso conto che detto fa così mara
venier ho sentito male dopo ma non
abbiamo affrontato l'argomento
mara scusami ti voglio bene
vi sedete stilista
accontenta felicissima eros altissimo
nativo per te pochi giorni dopo
twitter dove dice che era innamorato in
macchina una cosa del genere lo avevo 14
anni ho detto ecco ero io amore di stato
è scoperto che effettivamente non ero io
non ricordo quando ho scritto che mi
sono innamorato in macchina che mi
succede sempre penso pure con le
mascherine più facile quando propri
questa parte tutti immagini che il sotto
sia tutto simmetrico poi la tolgono vedi
picasso per la mascherina di la gente ha
dei bellissimi occhi e quindi parte
l'amore le poche volte in cui mi sono
innamorato 1 non c'eravamo incontrati
dal video che automaticamente prendevo
la foto dove era venuto più bello il
ragazzo come status quo menta invece
ragazzi ricordato sempre vi prego quando
state sottendere quando stato online
prendete la più brutta e partite
dall'inizio molto meno giudicante che ho
fatto un sacco di volte sesso concetto
che mi faceva cagare manieri
consapevolemente così a quel punto una
volta che aprì la porta di casa scopri
che è tutta una truffa di chase anche
all'ospitalità
quella che sarà capitato pure a voi
inutile che ripete è riconoscere un
periodo nel quale
errigo massimo raggio di azione di vano
frigo a un certo punto un giorno si
sveglia vado ad arezzo perché per vedere
la città e città storica importante e da
lì è diventato il trapano di arezzo
enrico posso dire che è veramente
squisito questo bravi praticamente
eravamo in città di quinto superiore a
decidiamo nido e altri tre ragazzi di
andare in discoteca merav a praga al
carlo milano e la cosa assurda è stata
quando siamo tornati di notte all'hotel
un nostro amico che era l'unico che
fumava ha detto dai ragazzi aspettate un
attimo qui fuori che il fumo una
sigaretta sentiamo sono come carta che
fa
crediamo in alto e c'era una pioggia di
260 euro ovviamente ci siamo fatti 50 60
quello che aveva pagato il taxi in
saluto a te guglielmo e all'ospite
professore claudio
intanto mi sembra di essere un bel
rimpiazzo grazie a praga l'unica cosa
che sono riuscito a fare la mia
professoressa di chimica che mi teneva
la testa mentre guidavo birra questi
chiesa caduti 260 euro e sono andato in
germania con una mia la scuola va bene
tutto l'anno si e ricordo che ho dovuto
fingere di fare sesso con noemi amica
pur di poter rimanere soli realtà poi ha
parlato e barbie capitato a lei lo
sapeva che stava spingendo oppure lei
era ignara e vittima della tua finzione
pagine domande scomode tu non ho capito
se è una tua dote rossetti c impegni
l'impegno che esistono delle ragazze che
effettivamente immettono in crisi ma
tuttavia preferisco essere gay piuttosto
che aggiungere anche la componente
vaginale all'interno del mio panorama
artistico non me la sento cioè se
iniziamo pure capito con la vagina non
finisce
dopo anni di fonda non accettazione di
difficoltà di tribolazioni proprio mi
sono guardato e ho detto l'alternativa
sarebbe stato essere etero e li ho
compreso il vero dramma 1 passa una vita
a dire non dovrei essere io non dovrei
essere che non dover essere gay ma mai a
pensare ma se tu siete rowe ti rendi
conto evviva lazzi e dal momento che
stiamo facendo è un gioco ragazzi sono
tutti quanti pregiudizi che si buttano
facciamo entrare la boxe del pregiudizio
[Musica]
come detto ai dritto vero
giusto dal piattino è tutto così
difficilmente raggiungibile e mi devo
gira per prende questo un movimento per
cui il corpo umano sia studiato il caldo
michele
un quaderno è un
carioca la boxe del pregiudizio funziona
in questo modo dovrai pescare a caso qua
dentro e tirar fuori un bigliettino
quello che dovrei fare alla fine sarà
rispondere alla domanda che leggi come
se fossi e tutto come se fossi me esatto
c'è un telecomando ecco dove cazzo qual
è il mio dt play è un errore farlo a
questo punto linea da solo insomma se
tante persone oggi
non ho mai pensato a quanto fosse strano
canto celine dion il mio guilty pleasure
quando sono a casa
in realtà è farmi il bagno luce spenta
in porta aperta nel tour a leccare il
tuo cane è veramente un altra
considerazione riguardo le repliche di
c'e posta per te è un grande prodotto lo
sa che l'ho scoperto ultimamente a che
età è stata la mia prima volta secondo
me tu non sei san michele capito
io ho questa sensazione che secondo me
da cattiva ragazza si la classica e
tanta cattiva ragazza 16 anni vicino 17
a 17
come è successo
mamma se stai guardando questo momento
vai avanti di un minuto praticamente io
avevo questa casa c'è la cucina
comunicante col salotto soltanto con una
porta scorrevole mia madre stava
cucinando in cucina con mia nonna e io
nel salotto la prima volta ma è
terribile ti dirò di più
stavo guardando
stavo guardando l'esorcismo di emily
rose bello sai che voglia di scopare che
cosa cambierei del mio aspetto fisico
questo è pesantissima per capire se
voglio essere sincero simpatico
loro hanno visto io credo che vorrei 5
cm in più di ogni cosa
ma
da cosa che questo tool questo 5 cm in
più di ogni cosa che avrebbe dovuto
vincere sanremo 22 2022
ma secondo me mahmood e branko il pezzo
più bello di così quando vengono qui
essere umili e
lo so devo dire se figurativo mai
inviato rudinì di una celebrity anno
dirlo io devo rispondere per te è andata
di lusso
[Musica]
ragazzi no veramente celebrity mai
madonna come se poco generoso io ho
fatto scritto un sì dirò di più che
questo è il mio grande rimpianto io mi
sono giocato la carta hollywood
grande celebrity e apprezzava molto io
stavo andando e poi non è chi non ci
credo che lo giuro non ci credo mai
nella vita passa il mio contatto trovo
che mandare in houdini a chi non è
famoso sia 100 minuti più eccitante si
sono inclusivo i rimanda tutti salutano
mai mandati no non mi chiedo e bussola
morale alto e sacramento ripercorrendo
il passato per un secondo che a mio
avviso la persona più sopravvalutata del
mondo dello spettacolo
scrivi n'è uno bechi gius per te la
persona più sopravvalutata non puoi
scrivere me perché sono tale va un
calcio note ante anche perché non faccia
più spettacolo da molto tempo io sono
stato onesto ma mi riservo di non
girarla aiutami sono state tre cantanti
maschio non avesse attaccato una donna
sarebbe stato molto video da parte tua
attaccare così una donna è stato viene
messo una donna no però aspetta non sta
per onestà questa è una persona che odio
ma obiettivamente molto talentuosa chi
non ha veramente talento merda vestita e
intonata almeno questo mi è venuta in
mente una peggio non ci credo hammami
oggi ragazzi michele bravi infuocato
secondo me quest'anno ha fatto sanremo
elisa pisa un dio che mi ha fatto una
canzone che a me un po mordini sarà la
forza di questa città cazzo dici però
tra le luci di questa città che cazzo me
ne frega ricercarti tra le luci di
questa città che il tuo cantante
preferito
elisa è una delle cantanti preferiti
l'anima vola cioè quando ti cerca e
soltanto perché le ti vuole ancora cioè
le ha scritto frasi di questo tipo per
le luci di questa città ma che cazzo sei
cioè una lampadina sono d'accordo ma se
vuoi ti faccio una descrizione di questa
persona che ho citato che è molto
sottovalutata per me è sopravvalutata
sopravvalutare così che ha detto io ogni
volta che ci parlo mi chiedo dove sia
finito
questa non la monteremo sono uscito una
volta mi sono annoiato a morte
oddio santo sai che anch'io questa
persona l'ho conosciuta deposta di una
cosa che rottura di [ __ ] che poi ti
chiedi ma
il cielo che ha acceso e non ho capito
se stanno un sacco di cazzate
ecco se potessi andare a letto con una
persona famosa del tuo ambiente vicino a
te quale sarebbe
se dovessi andare a letto con una
persona famosa del mio ambiente che
conosci che conosco ma ti sta offrendo
non ho capito come
in questa stanza siamo troppo primedonne
di immagini del tea lette insieme danno
questo bar cellino no no io ho letto
cambio molto come si è letto
non sei molto dire
scusate ragazzi brucerà queste cose come
è stata bruciata la biblioteca
d'alessandria
[Musica]
d'accordo la mostra
scelgo rocco siffredi è comunque una
cosa che oltre essere interessante mi fa
anche il curriculum ago era il tuo io ti
vedo sia solo fisicamente perché se devo
pensare al carattere
nessuno che tu sei confusionario cioè tu
peschi da un bacino molto più ampio
di chiamare mi ha rotto il cazzo se non
saprei sceglie manco io sono generosi ed
è con questo che chiudiamo
questo gioco nel quale ho dimenticato il
nome di
[Musica]
amore
eccolo eccolo vieri
e si vuole fare fare questo ma la
passaggi proprio
vieni qui famiglie delle servizio anche
contenti
ma ma se lo sta facendo pare certo
no non fare così senza questo questo non
è però da un po forte ha detto guarda io
ormai sono andato ascoltiamo l'ultimo
messaggio e poi ci salutiamo e stato un
piacere comunque ancora mi sono
trasferito proprio a volte sono andato
in scozia che sono finito in questa
stanza in un ostello giugno mi alzo mi
metto a leggere un libro sul kindle è
praticamente succede che mentre leggo
vedo dall'altro lato della stanza
all'altro angolo della stanza con tizio
che mi fissa e muove tutto il corpo in
maniera molto strana come se stessi
facendo le cessioni sul nero
conforto moretti c'è un forte rumore
sono di plus come se qualcuno toccasse
una busta l'elevato dalla stanza perché
il kitsch tra chiamando guardandomi non
ho capito il rumore della busta di
plastica io che pure non l'ho capita
cioè di materiale era la compagna non ho
capito no serio io guarderei per paura
che qualcuno possa svegliarsi adeguate
resti vendita altra gente ma cosa dici
partiamo che mi offende dal discorso
presupposto che mi offendi oltremodo io
ho fatto un sogno treason nella mia vita
a contarle il tu vai un'idea di me
secondo me posso dirtelo proprio
sinceramente perché basta fingere fidati
che io
guarderei per l'ansia di una persona che
si sveglia e poi
madama che guanti una persona perché
così tm ma se lo fa in una casa dei
sedici persone un po ce l'avrai come
feticcio li effettivamente non è male se
la metti così non è male vedo proprio
con la campagna vicino al letto che poi
ragazzi direi di chiudere questo video
[Risate]
michele siamo ai saluti finali grazie
ciao sono claudio grazie per per essere
stato mio ospite grazie per avermi fatto
scoprire un nuovo drink pazzesco
soprattutto ragazzi grazie anche a voi
per tutti quanti gli audio che ci avete
mandati erano così tanti che sono stati
addirittura riciclaggi di questa sveglia
mi dice
portati via la chinatown
[Musica]
sapere al fine di questo video grazie
minimi cane grazie a voi processi alla
stampa non mi piace insomma per cui
possiamo chiudere così a
non funziona prof comunque se fosse una
bella e la bestia st soddimo nando una
vecchia in questo momento io sto lì
mondo chicco
ragazzi ci vediamo non lo so quando ma
sempre qui ciao
[Musica]